bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur la rt fonce alors un moral au plus
bas pour les étudiants aux cycles
supérieurs détresse psychologique
solitude difficultés financières est-ce
que des étudiants vous ont raconté leur
quotidien
en ce temps de crise sanitaire oui alors
on a beaucoup d'étudiants qui nous
donnent leurs témoignages vous avez fait
l'écho dans ce reportage au groupe en
petit comité un groupe qui est parti sur
facebook
moi je suis pas mais le porte parole a
néanmoins eu aussi donc je reçois
énormément de témoignages en temps qui
lui on a beaucoup d'appels beaucoup de
messages sur facebook est également en
tant que représentant d'amphi où là il
ya une proximité bien plus importante
avec les étudiants plus particulièrement
de la fac de droit de l'université le
monde chacun font part de leurs
souffrances de cette détresse
psychologique et puis surtout de cette
exiguïté dans laquelle ils sont une
exiguïté donc dans leur appartement mais
aussi dans leur vie ya plus de vie
sociale
ils sont toujours face à leur ordinateur
en visio dongle peu de liens également
avec les professeurs
c'est assez compliqué des annonces inde
et manuela macron est ce que ces mesures
que le président comprendre sont à la
hauteur
je pense que c'est difficile de
d'estimer quelles sont à la hauteur ou
non la question c'est comment on va
pouvoir faire mieux li vé également ça
va être de rouvrir rapidement les amphis
il ya quelque chose qui travaillent qui
travaille beaucoup les étudiants à
l'université c'est pourquoi les
étudiants de bts d'iut de classes
préparatoires peuvent avoir accès à
leurs cours et par les étudiants de
l'université pourquoi on ne peut pas
avoir accès à noter que dès qu'on ne
peut pas aller à la faculté alors que à
l'université alors que d'autres le
peuvent
et cette injustice l ai vécu très
profondément par les étudiants on voit
qu'ils se mobilisent je pense que non ça
n'est pas suffisant dès lors que l'on
peut imaginer m
place des solutions pour des parcours
d'excellence comme les classes
préparatoires je pense qu'il faudrait
pouvoir le mettre en place également à
l'université alors on le rappelle un
manuel mâcon a par exemple promis des
chèques psychologique ou des repas à un
euro par jour
est ce que ce sont des mesures qui vous
paraissent applicable dans l'urgence
parce que on parle d'urgence
actuellement
alors elles sont pour la plupart déjà
appliqué les repas un euro elles
dépendent du crous ils sont donc
disponibles pour les étudiants boursiers
on appelle salir par l'emporter
on voit aussi qu'il ya énormément
d'associations qui comme gaelis par
exemple qui mettent en place des
épiceries solidaires avec justement des
repas plus accessible donc c'est bien de
mettre en place des mesures qui existent
déjà mais en fait on sait pas ce qu'on
demande c'est bien également un choc
psychologique mais l'étudiant car en
détresse psychologique s'est pas
particulièrement celui qui appelle et la
question c'est comment on va faire pour
aller tous ces étudiants qui souffre
véritablement est ce qu'un numéro vert
ça suffit est ce que si l'étudiant qui
souffrent n'appelle pas le numéro vert
il va prendre cet argent pour accéder à
ces psychologues et où sont tous ces
psychologues qu'on nous promet on nous
promet qu'à tout 80 psychologue de plus
en france où sont ils
on attend alors la majorité des cours en
cycle supérieur se fait majoritairement
en distance yens est ce que c'est
vraiment au nabeul très honnêtement non
eh bien je crois que je suis je peux
parler également au titre d'étudiante je
peux pas tenir toute la journée en cours
devant un ordinateur sans avoir une
migraine
on a énormément de cours qui durent très
longtemps un conte ses trois heures donc
quand vous en beauté avec cours de 8
heures jusqu'à 20 heures en écoutant des
audio ou bien des cours en direct on
décroche et ça c'est quand les
professeurs accepte de bien vouloir
faire leurs cours quand les professeurs
nous
80 pages des pdf en nous disant voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui et que vous
devez travailler tout seul il n'y a plus
aucun lien ya plus de renseignements et
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'on n'a
plus une formation complète en vinrent
en cours et on n'a plus la formation
pour laquelle on sait on ce étant donné
qu'en pour laquelle on a tant donné des
sorts et paradoxalement les examens sont
les mêmes
j'adore non vous voulez continuer non je
vous en prie merci en tout cas jacques
guillaume d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle peut être élu au
conseil d'administration de l'université
lyon iii pour l'association et gally
merci à vous d'avoir été en direct sur
arte france